just going live chair
yep you're now live okay anyways
we'll start the meeting then uh thank
you all for tuning up
it's it's it looks a very very good
turnout um and welcome to john art
who is going to again tell us our
well we're doing and how much money is
going to put into torridge for us
and generally all those things and
um so we'll get apology apologies who's
doing
the minutes tom it's merry christmas
okay
our merry chair okay mary um
apologies mary yes yeah we have
apologised from councillor gov
and council log of torridge district
council councillor hassell of little
little and land cross
right
worthy oh you okay that's fine
okay okay yeah that's fine mary thank
you
right we'll move on now we welcome
john art leader of devon county council
and he's going to give us his normal
speech
which he does every year which is very
interesting
so away you go john thank you very much
for the invitation
and i apologize for my voice i'm hoping
it'll last
out it's a bit quirkier than it was last
night
but at the same time i'm able to swallow
better than i could yesterday
so i'm definitely getting better right
um this is something we've always done
or i've done but this is my 12th year
somebody reminded me last night
um first time i came i had a board
and it was devanopoly and in those days
we had a degree of flexibility
on how much money we could play with
over the last few years we've had none
this year in particular we certainly
have got no
flexibility the
kovic pandemic has created mayhem in
local government finances
it created mayhem in national government
finances too
but with the county council we have been
given 43 million pounds
we have more than spent that simply
keeping the show on the road
in devon this year
the autumn statement came out
about 10 days ago at which
there has now been a promise that for
the first quarter of next year
the government will underwrite the
current
costs of local government we don't know
how much buy
but we do know that there's going to be
a bit of a cushion on that
we had when we set up the um
needs requirements in the county council
to cope with the pandemic um
we put in place things that we just
can't shut down
immediately there will need to be a
carryover
to run some of what goes on
into next year i've yet to be convinced
that we're going to finish this pandemic
much before the latter part next year
rather than the beginning yes we've got
a vaccine it's going to take a while
to vaccinate everybody in this country
so it won't be an easy one there are
different vaccines coming
it won't be easy for the government
it won't be easy for us all to queue up
and get
an injection the current injection needs
a
second injection 21 22 days after
therefore if you get the first one
remember to go back for the second where
you don't get
covered at the moment we're in tier two
as a county council
i said it was unfair a couple of weeks
ago we ought to be in tier one
ironically some of our districts
have got worse rather than better in the
last three weeks
and certainly one is substantially
higher
than the rest of the county and it's not
you
um two weeks ago i was blaming
exit i was blaming e.m plymouth and
torbay
but they were dealing with devon as an
entity
i have a worry that we will not come
down into tier one
for quite a little while there is a
review
on the 16th of december
i cannot see they were going to qualify
what i did say when i made the
announcement that i was
sad i said there was need for us to
support or government to support
the hospitality industry because
if we're not careful we will not have a
hospitality industry
in the spring of next year
whereas you can close down for a couple
of months
a lot of these businesses and they've
been shot for a better part of six
and although some have had government
help
some of that government help is now
coming to an end
and they're having to renegotiate their
loans from the banks and things like
that
i did say in september or october that i
was hoping
that the furlough scheme wasn't going to
stop in november
because i could not see people finding
jobs in december
the furlough is kept on until march
at least in march we should have a
reviving economy
so therefore people will be better
at the present moment we set the target
budget for next year
it goes before the cabinet tomorrow
it's 542 million eight hundred and
eleven
thousand pounds within that
we have no flexibility
we have actually had to take savings
and look at the way we can reduce
expenditure in the
autumn statement the minister very
kindly gave us an extra one percent
for adult care if we wanted to take it
or we could stretch it over two years so
we we were budgeting for two percent
they said
three percent they also said one point
nine
nine percent would be the maximum rise
for council tax
before you went for a referendum
now they also said at the same time by
giving us the one percent
they give us 4.2 million pounds if we
were to take it
what they also did was put up the
minimum wage by 2.2 percent
very few members of staff in devon
county get minimum wage
but an awful lot of people that work for
companies a tcc employee
do putting up minimum wage by 2.2
percent
has added an extra 3.3 million pounds
to our wage structure what with that the
600 000
charge for adult services and another
500
000 pounds for other reasons
we have in one hand been given the
opportunity
to raise 4.25 million
same time we were given the bill for 4.4
million
so you know beware god's giving you
gifts when you look at the small print
it's not there we don't actually know
what the
provisional settlement will be here
that's in about two weeks time
and we certainly don't have a clue what
the final settlement is going to be
we've been promised for two years that
we would have a three-year plan
unfortunately we've had a one-year plan
last year
and a one-year plan this year you can't
budget easily on that those of you that
have read the papers
know that we have an overspend
in the send special needs children
special education needs last
financial year with 19 million the
government
changed the rules uh three years ago
put more emphasis and responsibility
onto local government but did not fund
it
we're not an outlier every
local authority with children in care
has got the same problem this year
well that's last year we 19 and a half
million
this year we're at the present moment
predicting something close to 25 million
overspends
the government has said that we're not
to charge that to council tax
we're to put it in a negative budget
line
so when we have the end-of-year
financial statement
we balance our books but at the bottom
there is something saying you have
always spent
19 and a half minutes the end of this
financial year
it'll be 45 million
as i've said to the government as well
as everybody else
it's all very well putting in a negative
budget line
but you've got to pay the bills in my
cash
so unless the government sorts something
out there's a lot of local authorities
going to be financially if not insolvent
embarrassed in year three
now as i say we're looking at a
draft budget of 542 million
we're increasing the adult services by
6.2 percent we
and children services by seven point one
adult services has an extra sixteen
point two million
current sales is ten point three
we've had all sorts of pressures on us
this year
we're still paying for the rural bus
service
there's actually haven't been very many
people on it although we did get some
support from government
we're paying for the early 60s bus pass
the bus
companies not getting very many
passengers
this is an interesting way of working
i agree with you that it has distinct
advantages
but i do actually miss driving around
down
and visiting people although i will
admit
but tonight i have twice as many people
listening to me
than i normally have so thank you torch
for turning out
i could talk a lot more but i think it
might be better
if i take questions i set the scene
the scene is we're in a very tight spot
we will get our cancelled tax
this year or the vast majority because
ironically the district councils are
committed to pay us
now at the present moment i understand
the districts are collecting
within two percent of what they were
committed to
to collect they're also
paying up or collecting the business
rates
the business rates you collect and send
to london
they send back to us we get nine percent
and then we get some form of formula
the end result is we get just over 100
million pounds
in business rates this year
virtually all the business rates for the
businesses are still going
were being paid for by the government so
we got the money
next year we don't have some businesses
we will be short of money the government
is offered this year
to reinstate up to 75
of lost council tax we don't have a clue
what that is yet
and we won't until after april the first
i think it is
when we get the good news at the end of
march we'll get an idea
with settlement videos but
government has has offered us some help
there
but at the moment we have
i want to say we have a very difficult
financial situation in the country a
difficult financial situation in devon
consolation for them is we do have a few
reserves
so we're not as destitute as dorset
and other local authorities who have
been named recently
neither have we invested in property in
shopping centers etc unlike tour bay
you've just had a revaluation and
they're
quite a few million lower now than when
they bought the place
i'll stop and i'll take questions that's
all right with you
okay yeah thanks thanks for that john um
i'll i'll open it up now
anybody want to uh i think oh yeah okay
first one to go then is councillor ames
torres district council
peter thank you chad thank you uh thank
you councillor hart for your
um for informing us of what's going on
in the county
which is what most of us suspected um
pretty dire situation
um yes i am a torridge
district councillor a lead member for
climate change and i'm also an autumn
town councillor
and chair of the climate emergency
committee work um
on that council um i just wanted to
raise the subject of cycling with you
and
what's called the active travel agenda
we have an active travel group uh
torridge
which is promoting and trying to
identify and promote cycle routes
and pedestrian routes and also horse
riding routes
i should add which would link in
link communities really link settlements
and we've had several meetings
also at northern we're engaged in the
same
pursuit we've had several meetings at
torridge on
the active travel group and we've
prepared a number of proposed route
cycle routes
um but we are very conscious
that it's difficult to get some sort of
linkage with the county council
um in terms of getting through our
projects really
um so that's on a general as a general
point i wanted to ask your advice and
how we can further
this agenda to to get more cycling
safe cycling in the torridge area and
also specifically about the ken
um a kenworth um cycle trail
which link would link biddeford and
westwood ho which is actually
on the county um
plan um for alternative transport
alternative travel but which has been on
for a number of years but
which has been held up because of a
couple of
land ownerships which um
the owners are reluctant to allow the
trail to go through
so we'd very very much like to know
on that specific trail how we can get
things going on that as well there is
money allocated by the county
um for for doing that so
welcome your comments please um
active travel was brought out by the
government
um in fairness the county council didn't
get that much money and we were given a
very short time to spend it
and we did it in the urban areas um we
did it in exeter we did it in basketball
um it hasn't met with universal approval
i'll be honest i
am and it's ironic quite a number of
local authorities have put in the
original
and they've taken the most account we're
not doing that
but we we well it's not true we have we
have taken one out
because gradually it made less sense
but we then got money to to
properly do the job but it was in
devon's terms
not very much off the top of my head i
think it was just over a million
and that doesn't go far when you're
talking about
the local authorities roughly 80 miles
by 100
by road 100 by 120
when we get bottle money last year
um 25 higher than any other local
authority
because we have 25 more roads than any
other local authority
i think we have something close to 8 000
miles of road
last year we got 25 million pounds for
part-time money
the nearest other county in the country
or
well yes county or unitarian country got
only 20 million
i do know a bit about the ruby way i do
not know about the kenworth
but i've got ali boyd with me and ali
will take that one up
if we have land issues i knew we do have
this
uh with we have had it on other schemes
as well
and that does create a problem
i can't answer that one but i'm happy
to come back to you with some more
information
okay um when it comes to money
for cycle ways the county did invest
in some of the long ones um
like um
and we're doing one of the momentum in
the south homes
oh i know it's it's in 10 bridge
actually
but it's a coastal one and we've done
one from exeter
to eczema so we are in it
but we have a big county and
i think we if i'm realistic it's going
to be a
little while unless we get people
prepared to work
with us for us to be able to link up
some of these
um cycleways it would be wrong with me
to say anything else if i'm honest
okay but i will look into it for you and
i will come back um
ally will come back and get councillor
homes i'll contact you direct and get
some more information
so that john and i can have a discussion
about it thank you
we still have a little bit of money left
in the airport i do know that
it could be that money has been
allocated to you okay
okay thanks for that thanks john um
right next one
is councillor hackett
thank you thanks pete and um thank you
chairman
i'd just like to return to cycleways
while we're there
um you are visiting virtually
the district that is most or was most
impacted by the introduction the minimum
wage
so any investment in torridge is most
eagerly thought sought um
i've got a declarable interest here
because i work for the british horse
society as a regional access officer
and i work all over the south west
and i just enlighten the group
as to the work that is going on in the
moment
in gloucestershire they're working on
the striat water canal which is
in in delivery two greenway projects at
stroud and cam
the techbury trail and embryonic funding
bids to link so ancestor cheltenham and
oxford
in somerset they're working to the rail
to trail project and
an extension to the strawberry line and
the peer-to-peer
trail in cleveland endorse it and i note
what you say about dorset
this last week i've been busy with a
consultation on
a 78 million pound grant under
transforming cities project
which will give a delivery of over 100
pounds 100 million pounds
for bournemouth christchurch pool
and also got an additional cycleway that
i'm working on
in devon i'm not getting anything
forward and i hear what you say about
cambridge
i hear what you say about etsy to
exmouth now when we tackled
our county councillor barry parsons on
this
he said well the trouble was in 2008
we had the recession and austerity
well that isn't a reason why we ne
get neglected in this area because we've
had gem bridge opened in 2012
we've had the double waters bridge
consultation come out to me
this year for over a hundred thousand
pounds
we discussed at our last meeting the
holes were the viaduct and where the
half million went to that
de chadric announced before his death
there is also the missing link on the
tarka trail that hasn't been
addressed which is urgently awaited
because that will bring prosperity this
area
and furthermore we have the issue of the
finishing of the ruby way between
viewed and to hold worthy and filling in
the missing links
now that is absolutely vital for the
economic
delivery to this area
of tourism i cannot overstate how much
that would mean to us
and councillor parsons you know i know
this
is you know he's being replaced at the
next election i do wish him well for the
future
but with dead shadrick it was
holesworthy
first with barry it's been
holesworthy coming up the rear if you
like because we have been deprived of
what we need
um you know barry was talking about the
money that was coming in for the ruby
way but equally
he was talking about the pegasus way
which isn't even in holesworthy division
so really we've got to have this
completed here
now notwithstanding that we could open
up
the existing cycleways for equestrian
use
and having spoken to ross mills who is a
manager of your rights away department
she said we can't afford to do risk
assessments
well i cannot believe that i cannot
believe that john
can we at least have something simple as
that done
which will enable equestrian bed and
breakfasts and
riding staples to flourish in this area
it would mean so much for us
so i would like your comments on that
and clarification on the money for
holdsworthy viaduct
right story basics i can't give you
anything i possibly buy as such i know
where it is
and i know that you've got a psycho way
to play with it
um but i can't talk in detail on that
i do remember the ruby way and the
target trail
and we just surfaced or resurfaced some
of the turkey trail
i can't talk in finnish on about risk
assessment
i am not sure with a number of these
long distance cycleways
stroke footpaths that the horses will be
that welcome
i par i beg to interject here because
your own laugh wants that to happen and
also
when they were set up the preferred
option
of devon county council was multi-use
now could you since the 1968 act
horses are allowed sorry cyclists are
allowed on bridal ways no problems
so why do you say what they would not be
welcomed when nationally
sustrans welcome them and they put that
out on their leaflets
and also you don't get any conflict of
interest nationally and also
um the department of transport talk
about non-motorized
usage to include horses it's all there
in legislation
i don't dispute that there's been a hell
of a growth in horses
what i'm saying to you is i'm not sure
some of these
are capable of taking horses and
cyclists and pedestrians
together they're not necessarily wide
enough
and that's something i would need to
find out from ross mill
mills you say she hasn't got the risk
assessments
but she hasn't got the time or she
hasn't got the ability i will find out
about that
what i equally know is if you have a
right away you get horses on it
if you have a footpath
nowadays we're getting horses on it too
i might as well be honest on that and in
your neck of the woods
it was one of the reasons why we were
looking at developing some years ago
the ruby way so that would be
a linkage for horses to travel from one
end of your constituent or your
your district to the other i will say
that torres was listed very recently
as one of the 10th
most vulnerable councils for economy
and that does no good for devon it does
no good for torridge
so if we can do something for you we
will
but you have given me a list of issues
there
that i can't in fairness answer to
because they're detailed i can talk in
general terms and my book is
i can talk in general terms about
highways i can talk in general terms
about schools
what i can't do is answer a specific
i can talk about the talk of troubling
ruby way i know where they are
but i cannot actually talk and i know
the jim bridge
i've been over there can i talk
in detail about the pegasus way i
i will press you on what you said
about the widths of the cycleways these
are former railway lines
yeah there is adequate space they are
wider than the camel trail which gets
four hundred thousand visitors per
per year down on it and four hundred
thousand movements
they are well capable of having
equestrian use
and also your laugh a statutory body
within
in the in them county council the decaf
has requested multi-use and that is your
preferred policy
and i cannot see why you have that
opinion
when a railway line is wide enough for a
train
and yet not for a horse and the standard
width of a bridle weighs three meters
which accommodates all anyway so i
really would
press you on that point
chair if i may come in yeah this me it's
ally
um chair if i may come in what i've done
uh in the past for
councillor parsons is get specific
information
from the officers concerned because it
is very difficult to
answer specific questions um when
when when you're not part of that
service so i can certainly
get answers to specific questions from
the offices and i have done for barry
in the past and i will do for john in
this instance but
um in terms of of pressing for answers
now um i i don't think that's going to
be possible
sorry okay well one last one last point
on this issue and then i'll come back
i'll sit down
but to complete the route to bude
and councillor parsons is saying that
there will be certain routes certain
roads
that will be stopped up and this
concerns me greatly
and i will personally
prevent this happening because it should
they should not be removed from the list
of streets
we should not be closing down
public highways because we feel they
should be taken off the defensive map
and it it i cannot if they
that there are roads out towards bude
that
are trafficked and are necessary and
should be kept open
to reduce the public highways there is a
maximum in law
once a highway always a highway and
i would resist that very strongly
because
cannot actually close roads was that as
simple as that
this is what said what we have done
is turn some of our roads into quiet
words
by putting up signs for safety for
horses etc
and persuading the locals not to use it
in the volume that they did in the past
what i can also tell you is the darker
trend over the last six months
has been very much loaded with people
loaded with cycles in a way that it's
never been before
there has been a massive increase in
cyclists
and pedestrians and you know whether we
like it or not
it has grown we also have at the present
moment
a large increase over the last few years
of horse people
i'm not sure and i said to you i'm not
sure they're wide enough to take
some of these are wide enough to take
the horses
i hear what you say about it needing or
dcc priority if it's a green lane
there's no question what's gonna have
the right to be on it
it is a footpath that's been taken over
by cyclists
or needs to review and see whether or
not it's practical
because in your horse fraternity today
we have a lot more young people and not
necessarily
know quite how to handle their horses
i object to that comment i can't look
at it tell it just calm down okay
calm down let let john finish
i just get to say there is there are a
lot more young people on horses today
not all control their horses the way
they should
and you if you're honest
will know the accidents that take place
i have a motion and full council
for the next four council on this to
make life safer
for horse riders
can i just could you send me the
evidence
of where there are accidents taking
place because with horses and cyclists
there have been no reports of this
nationally
on cycleways yes cycleways have become
much busier nationally
there have not been accidents reported
look at the busyness of the top
of the camel trail down in cornwall and
how that works
i really do think there's been some
prejudice here
against horse riders contrary to
your own policy at dem county council
and cons
um contrary to the recommendations of
the decaf which is a statutory body
so i would like that take into account
and i would welcome seeing the evidence
set before me that you speak of about
inappropriate use
i think ali ali boyd would collate this
evidence won't you john and send and
send it to well certainly
we are we're doing it now strangely
enough because
we have this motion that we've produced
a cabinet
of all councils last thursday and it has
to be reported to
the cabinet in january so we will have
some information for you on
all of this on the safety angle the
number of people
that have been injured in devon on
horses
is all going to be collated okay so i'm
quite happy to have that circulated
when the time comes i was going to say
i'm aware of the notices of motion that
going forward but they won't be ready
immediately it will be early next year
then okay and send it to it okay yeah
i'm furiously writing notes
cheers okay next one in line
peter christie catholic christie you're
on next
thank you uh good evening john um i'm
the mayor of biddeford
and uh vice chairman of torridge um i've
got two questions one's
specific to biddeford the other is more
general um
i'll do the specific one first because i
suspect allison will
need to go back on this um biddeford
library
the building is owned by torridge and we
let it to the county council
on a peppercorn rent but before covid
there was a lot of talk about the
library moving
and it's all gone quiet because of cobit
but clearly
if it does move and we do need a new
library
this has implications for both torridge
and devon so that's my first question
a second more general one um i have
actually met you in biddeford you've
come to a bit of it several times
and you will know that biddeford is very
hilly and one of the big problems is
every time we get a heavy rainstorm
and we're going to get more with climate
change
the hilly streets of biddeford are like
rivers
because the big problem is all the
drains have blocked
and when we've brought this up with
julian ross gilly who's our
area man um he says he has a
rotor for clearing these but some of
them only get cleared once in three
years
and it does lead to flooding and i had a
recent case where a woman
was actually flooded in the middle of
the night in devon county had to send
workers out
to try and clear the drain outside her
house i wonder is any chance of
increasing the number of drain
clearances
thank you okay job of the dream is
frustrating
and as much we do have a policy um if we
have a train that's
kind of blocking on a regular basis
normally it gets
treated more than once every three years
uh alec can you check on the flooding in
beautiful for me
because i know i haven't got that down
yeah i've got that down
check on the road trying with barnstable
was a lot more complicated because
we had a short tillage a monsoon rain
and that came down and the drains
couldn't cook
and a wall was washed out because of the
volume but after about four hours
water had all gone again and that is a
problem i think we do have nowadays
yeah i can check on that
volume of rain um sorry ally
no sorry i also know quite a bit about
the uh potential move of the library and
what's happened there
so i can get the latest report on that
and
and get back that certainly was on the
cards at one stage
it was and in fairness it's been on the
coach for a while
the only thing i would say about
libraries is a semi-removed organization
from the county council
its libraries unlimited and they are
running they run themselves um
gadget gives them some money but they
run themselves
when we were reviewing our finances
and we have dropped or we have reduced
our expenditure by about 300 million
pounds a year
now is a accumulative figure
but that is basically what this coming
budget this year
if we had the equivalent in 2010
without the reductions we had to have we
don't bet about 300 million
more we decided to set the
libraries up in a semi freestanding
organization
and on the back of that we didn't shut a
single library
whereas many of our colleague local
authorities
decimated their libraries but ali if you
can look into that one for me
without libraries unlimited um and give
us the up today or give them the up to
date where they are
because off the top of my head yeah and
i'm happy to do
that it's gonna happen there was an
issue there was a couple of issues there
there was a couple of issues um and i
know that
um sean kearney and i worked on it at
some point
so did dave slocum and there was issues
around
the land the ownership of the of the
site where the library might have been
moved to
all sorts of things but i can certainly
get a comprehensive report
to everybody
are you happy with that okay thank you
okay yep right move on to the next one
tony inch where are you oh yeah yeah yes
here i am
all right can you hear me yeah yeah
right yeah good evening john long long
time they'll see but
never mind um
all right just to come back uh on the um
the public rights away uh i think um
ross uh mills is coming to the next
uh torres active uh travel group so
i think she'll be able to bring along a
lot of knowledge and a lot of
information to that so that that's good
and um
in the advanced change rights away i sit
on that committee as well for porridge
and it is a very interesting um
committee and whenever we get
uh big developments in biddeford we
always try
and we always do insist on
cycle routing development areas and we
try to
link them up with the time which isn't
easy
because as you know biddeford wasn't
even built
cars out of the old you know lorries and
everything else that goes through there
so it is a bit of a problem um
the other thing was as well um the
drains that
uh coachella christie mentioned he did
contact me actually at men's street with
the trains that was caused not by our
drains actually but it was
and two men from the county did come out
and
try and help it was caused by by run off
from a
from a neighbor's roof um down a broken
down pipe which flooded into her
uh lounge so um i have tried to sort
that out and
and i think torrids have tried to sort
out with contact in the
the land it was a rented property so
they've contacted the land
lando owner of the house owner to try to
get that sword out so
you know and trains are there is there
is a map
or a a map somewhere that
says which strains will be covered
um cleared some more clear
uh in a three mil year cycle some in the
two year cycle
uh so you know and and of course with
drain clearing
it's always a problem in towns like
biddeford where
cars are actually parked over the drains
when they come to clear them
so you know it is a problem but
uh anyway that's a little bit of
information for you chair
thank you very much tony we'll move on
uh cancer david chalmers i think your
northern
town council's mayor that's right so i
am
um good evening council health yes i'm
david charms i'm the mayor of northern
and thank you very much for coming this
evening and uh
you know giving us that information is
very interesting
um i'm gonna actually echo what and
there's
definitely a theme on here this evening
but i'm going to echo what councillor
haines has said
um and what council christie that we
would like to see
the cycle routes made more of a priority
um for our area certainly i know the
the the route that uh council haynes
mentioned
kenworth valley which ran along the old
um
railway line route that it was if that
was opened up would be the way
for young people from biddeford to be
able to access the sea
without having to take driving cars or
taking public transport
um so i mean the well-being the
development of tourism in our area
it really is something that we would
like to see made a priority and for for
the county to invest in
there is another route as well which we
in uh
in northern are very interested in and
it is the cherchum lane
route that runs along the torridge river
and would link up appledore with
uh biddeford and would not take that
much
um investment to actually turn that in
into into a cycle route so
i mean i'd like you to have a look at
that one as well but i just feel that as
others have said
that uh certainly torridge the town
councils
biddeford northam um we
are having these discussions i i and i
know that the the county has
you know been sending representatives
but i just would like you to actually
try to make this more of a priority as
well because
this is really important for our area
not only for as i said for tourism for
the investment
for the well-being of people living here
but it would be a real boost to the area
at the moment that that needs it
because uh you know we've had a very
a difficult year and i think we're going
to have another difficult year ahead of
us and so something like this would
really be a boost to our area
so thank thank you i was actually up in
your area beginning of the year
um and i was looking at among other
things that happened to a shipyard as
well
as they say this is interesting and as
much
we are very geared around cycleways
today
um and we'll certainly take up
and i will get updated on where we are
with all this
and get you answers okay yeah thanks
thanks john
thank you jamie mackenzie you're there
you're on parsons not before me no no
you're shown on my list first
okay then um i would just like to
ask for a review of the way that
highways are funded
um as i believe the distribution of
money goes by councillor
and there's more councillors in the
south of devon than there are in nor in
the north of devon
um torrid has only got five councillors
so
you know there's a disproportionate
amount of money going to
smaller road networks so we've got a
large road network
up here that's very uh well not in a
good state of repair
and it seems to be that the distribution
of money is not
right um i'd like that to be reviewed if
possible
indeed in exit there is one area with
two councillors so they've got double
the amount of money to spend on their
highway so
um is it fair do you think john
or councillor heart sorry
um i'm slightly struggling on this
i think what you're talking about is a
small allocation of money that each
candy cancer
board gets in preference but that's a
very small amount of money
in relation to the 57 million pounds a
year
they get spent on highways
the vast majority of the money spent on
highways is spent on need
base we have got as i said in the
beginning 8 000 miles of road
and on the 8 000 miles of road we have
the loadings we have a certain amount of
world
that we're not responsible for which is
the national highways it comes down to
highways england
but within our setup what i will say is
we have changed
one of the policies lately we've stopped
doing
this instantaneous response
to potholes as such and we're doing
patching now
rather than potos and it certainly is
saving us money
we're doing a bigger area in the first
place and that and cutting it out
properly
that is saving highways people coming
back
um at extra times the money that
goes to the county councillor for
spending i in fairness don't know how
much it is
but it is only a small sum in relation
to what we're talking about
and it so happens you're right you have
five county councillors
west evan has four other places got
eight
ten or seven but
at the same time it means they've got a
much higher population
they may not have a higher set of roads
definitely built and i said this last
time
devin's roads were developed for the
horse and cars
they haven't really got foundations but
we're putting 40 ton lorries on them
and 30 ton tractors and we wonder why
some of them break up
they literally are not built or they
were never built
our villages weren't built or some of
our villages were not
built for this kind of traffic but
we share that small amount of money per
county councillor
some county councils as i said we'll
have bigger areas to cover
but that is only a very small proportion
of the highway money
you get on top of that the county
divides the money up on a needs basis
not actually by the mile necessarily
and certainly not that you're
what should i say you're losing out
simply because
you haven't got that many county
councils
if i can interject chair i think i think
what john's
describing to jamie is the locality
budget
which is um a budget that the
councillors
have had year on year it's not
guaranteed every year
um but but generally they've had it year
on year and that can be spent on any
community project
including highways projects however
it can't be spent on a highways project
that is
actually our responsibility as a county
council
so it can only be spent on extra work
towards the highways that we wouldn't
actually have within our highways
budget anyway so it as
john was saying at the moment is ten
thousand pounds per member per year
um and that is is spent on
a number of community uh projects
including some highways but we're not
allowed to spend it on highways projects
that we would be
responsible for as a county council um
john's quite right in saying that we
have a a budget that comes through
specifically for highways works and that
is
calculated the spend on that is
calculated in a totally different way
nothing to do with how many members
there are
ali can i just say every
um local highways officer gets a small
allocation of money
to spend in their patches which is then
the local county council has the right
to try
within a a bit of a um
bid for if i put it there yeah yeah
so occasionally a parish
will have a particular corner that's
caused problems for a while
and the highways engineer is officer
will spend some of his money on that
it is over and above the locality budget
what i don't know
is how much it was per county councillor
um but it was more than ten thousand
pound per councillor right
but it was it would seem though that the
north um
of the county has a crumbling
infrastructure of its highways with
downgraded roads
um etc um and obviously
up here you know we've got a lot of
rural roads and and down in
like extra etc there's a lot more major
roads and obviously the allocation of
money is going to the major roads
so you know the the a roads and then
trickles down to the other categories of
road since we've got
less of the higher categories of roads
up here you know
and we've got a lot of people traveling
around
where's you know it just doesn't seem
that the allocation of
time and resources is fair to our
highway infrastructure i mean the link
road is is terrible
and it's been terrible for years it's
not really you know it's not a
short it's not happened over a short
time it's happened over a long time
um there are junctions uh like at
westwood hope on the link road
um and it's i think that you're probably
waiting for
like some sort of money coming from
development to upgrade that junction but
in the meantime
it's deteriorating and it's been bad for
years i mean
i just don't see the fairness in the way
that the timing resources
are allocated around the county
perhaps that's my perception i don't
know i'm quite happy for somebody to
persuade me otherwise
can i say to you that i can't answer the
question
in detail like that i can say that we
put the safe domain road in we're just
in the process of spending 60 million
pound on the north america
um that we do spend bro
um we spend money on roads because last
year i came to your meeting
i went back to where i was coming back
to extraordinary shortcut
find the rope blocked off completely
while they were doing a long stretch of
work
um there is a lot of money going into
highways
i'm not sure i can but i'm getting to
ask
how much money has gone into
um cambridge torres district council
area
over 12 months and i said i'll get you
the answer yeah wish you would john that
would be all right
thank you okay
oh just one more thing that just really
irks me and dwells for here
um bridget structures our um benefit
long bridge has had its um coping stones
done and they've been done for several
years now
we were assured that they would um uh
become like the other ones you know with
lichens on and sort of like blend in
but they're still like they were the day
they were laid you know completely wrong
material etc etc
i'm wondering why our grade one national
monument has been allowed
to be abused in such a callous
you know manner that's one i can't
answer
i do know there was a question about
fireworks
last new year um
as well you should have fireworks the
waves gonna scare the birds
um but i will ask what material is put
in there
how long ago was it done oh god it must
be
four or five years ago okay i mean i
suppose the other thing is
if you've got polluted air it colors
quicker
this isn't coloring at all i mean i was
told that it could have been them
artificially done with
yogurt and cow manure um but obviously
nobody was really interested in making
it match
and it's it stands out like a sore thumb
it's absolutely
horrendous how that's been done anyway
that's me finished
just okay just to say jamie i've got a
nice long list of questions to go back
to offices with for john
you ain't finished yet you ain't
finished yet
right but uh but barry
um if i just might um say a few words
chairman please in response to uh
certain things that have been said
um this evening um and uh certainly
councillor hackett is right about one
thing uh that is that i
i am not standing no uh at the next
election and therefore
you know i'm certainly not on the
campaign trail what you what i say
is um is absolutely as far as i know the
absolute truth
i want to start off just by saying a few
things about um
the ruby trail i want to say first of
all
no one loves horses more than i do i've
looked after
horses for years i've had my own i've
raced them
um and um i think very fondly of them
and anything i can do to assist in their
welfare
um i will certainly do john knows john
hart knows
very well the amount of pressure that i
put on county council
so does dave black who said of planning
in terms of trying to get things
done not just in holdsworthy but in
torridge generally
because some of the things that have
been said tonight are absolutely right
um in terms of funding yes in terms of
funding going back to 2009
when i became a county councillor that
was the time if you remember
when we started moving into austerity
and we've been faced with that pretty
much all the way
since that period of time it has not
been
easy um there are things that have been
done
in torridge there are things that have
been done in holesworthy
and i want to um just tell you that um
des shadrick who was my predecessor was
a wonderful
wonderful counselor i had an awful lot
of time and respect for him not just as
a counselor but also as a human being
they were times previous to 2009
when money was spent quite fluidly
we haven't had the opportunity to be
able to do that since that period of
time
and i think um generally and across the
country
you will find that devon has a
particularly high
reputation i've only got to cite devon
has been one of the 11 beacon councils
in this country
for how we've responded in terms of this
particular pandemic as well
i think we can be proud of an awful lot
of things
in terms of road closure um
in mentioning road closure i want the
full context to be given here
because any road closure that would
occur would certainly have to go through
a full consultation process
all right so i don't want words being
used that are taken out of context and
that's very
important from my point of view i also
want to mention
that there's no external grant funding
for such schemes
uh like the ruby way and we're largely
reliant on the local transport plan
funds as well as developer contributions
but these are mainly
urban focus to to progress our
cycle aspirations now unfortunately that
means that there are pigeon steps
and we we've committed yes to over the
next two years to complete the pegasus
way
and continue progress with the ruby way
now
the last substantial government grant
funding announcement
for leisure cycle infrastructure was the
cycling ambition fund which was back in
23
2013 and yes that was the granite and
gears program and yes that is on dart
ball
um but we can't do everything at the
same time
now although the government earlier this
year announced 2 billion for walking and
cycling
this as john has said so far it's only
been for urban cycle infrastructure and
we're waiting further details
of what future funding might come
forward to support
our rural routes and that that's
massively important
now in terms of the ruby way evan county
council's commission work to negotiate
with the land owners
for an alternative route to avoid hold
station campsite
now that's um instead of making use of
quiet lanes to rejoin the trail at worry
forest near whole world
there's been funding 150k as i recall
over
uh the next two years that have been
already been put in place
to address that kind of issue now
earlier to
this year the cabinet approved the
transporting infrastructure plan
which included a number of walking and
cycling aspirations
in north devon as well as storage and
i'm quite happy to i've got this in
front of me now
quite happy to share this with everyone
and let ali have it so that
she can forward it on to people but
there are
areas of that in which um for example
um the whole world to holdsworthy cycle
route
uh which is a re-recycled link from
whole world to to holdsworthy
that's been earmarked for um around 300
000 pounds between
20 uh 2020 and 2023.
that is our plan and that's through that
local transport plan
so um chairman i'll i'll leave it at
that i will get some of this information
over to ali myself
because i've got a fair bit of this
already which in truth i've already
shared with an awful lot of people
in my award thank you chairman okay
all right very very much okay
chris leather where are you oh there you
are it's your turn
thank you chair good evening john thanks
for
attending this evening i've i've been to
many of these meetings over the years
that you've been at
i uh i sit on torres district council i
chair the plans committee
and i'm also a northern town councillor
and what i'd like to ask is
is to do with education in new schools
there's a very large site in northam
it's called the daddon hill farm site
nor01
nor01 it's in the north devon and torres
local plan
the first phase of that was recently
given reserve matters
planning permission full planning and in
that phase one
is a new 420 place primary school
with associated nursery and children's
center
now that service site which the
developer has to provide
should hopefully be available later next
year
they're hoping to start this scheme at
any time now
actually um and it's the first 130
houses of 500
on the site now i've been telling people
that once that service site is available
and the money for it in the section 106
education contributions
has been coming in towards that from
various sites in the area
but if it's not enough to build that
school straight away i've been telling
people
the county council can approach the
government
and get the funding for that school and
then repay the government
once the one or six contributions come
in
can i have a promise that once that
service site is available
that devon will get on and get that new
primary school built because
in the area john we're absolutely
busting at the scenes with our primary
school
thank you okay thank you very much for
that
um firstly if we have
this kind of development if it's a big
school uh sorry big a big
site and it must be a fairly big site
420
place um primary school
um if it comes in in phases what we
normally do is we put it
a half school or the developer puts in a
half score
of 210 and then it gets expanded
now i can't speak on this particular
scheme
if what i do know is local government
doesn't actually
build schools anymore we go to the
government
they have a priority list they give us
cash for specific schemes
i'm not sure on this is a brand new
school is it going to be part of an
academy chain
or is it going to be on its own this is
a brand new school
because many of the new schools have to
be sponsored
by somebody this will be a brand new
school
john yeah but is it being sponsored by
anybody not that
other than the developer yeah right okay
well i will get this looked at
and i will come back to you and we have
in christia of course sorry um
you know we have officers that can deal
with this for me okay but
assuming you've started on site
and assuming they're going to build the
school the developer normally builds a
school as well
because it's in the developers interest
to have a good school
on site it sells houses better
the commitment it's not all their money
and it's money from other sources as
well
then the county will be involved in this
and i would need to know exactly how
much
money is in the pot and how much
is going to be needed and whether or not
anyone i could ask how many houses going
on the site
500 eventually and this is the first
phase with 130 houses
right but in what we've done in many
circumstances they say
is build a half school with it with a
nursery and then
the other half follows through when the
next
year clicks in on number of properties
yeah and that's what i don't know and
that's what i need to check
yeah thanks john the main the main thing
i was asking is because the schools
two school schools in appledore are
absolute capacity
the schools in northern are at capacity
and this new school
on this site is to cater for the
not the overflow but to cater for the
pupils that come within
any of those and what i really needed
was once this
the developer has only got to provide
the service site there's a site there
and and then it's up to the county
council to get a new school but
that's slightly different okay i didn't
get that looked at
certainly the score the developer will
be responsible
for more i would suggest on 500 houses
for 500 properties more than simply a
service site
but i will get it looked at john john i
can get hold of simon niles and get
the latest
it's only a service site that's been
it's there to hand over to devon county
the developer aren't going to build
build the school they're not going to
build the school
no right okay
yeah that's fine as i say of late
where i've been involved in lately the
developers admittedly slightly larger
size than this
the relatives developers are building
the site they're building the score
themselves
in phasers so we'll get the answer to
you for that
one okay yeah thanks john
linda ellia where are you
hello right i'm i'm here
hello hello john is it all right if i
come back i've been listening
for anyone doesn't know i'm county
councillor for bidding for east division
and i'm on biddeford town council
and lots of the topics you've covered
are people talking about are in my area
so is it okay if i come back yes
yeah well biddeford longbridge i think
it was done in 2017
and um jamie jamie mckenzie was talking
about the stones not blending in
um kenneth dente who's kevin tendee
head of bridges instructors assured me
at the time
that those stones actually came from the
same quarry
that the bridge was built from and they
will weather in time
and he sent photos which i showed
biddeford town council at the time of
horror bridge
bridge which was similarly done
and if you go on the bridge one side of
it is weathering quicker than the other
because it must get more brunt of the
weather
but but that's the case with the bridge
um with the cycling i'm also on the um
public rights away committee with with
tony
and we're i think it's tomorrow we've
got the active travel meeting at
torridge
and ross mills is coming to that um
and on the cycling trail very much
through the chemwith valley
and the turkum lame one but i i do know
that there are issues the issues in the
kenworth valley with the route
in that the private landowners don't
want to sell
and from what me asking highways
i understand cherchum lane is private
land again
so they beat the stumbling blocks with
the cycling
and i think with the tarka trail and
horses
um from just my discussions with roz
is that if you're um designing a new
trail for example through the kenwood
valley
that could accommodate everyone it
horses cyclists
um pedestrians but you can't
retrospectively
necessarily turn um an existing trail
into something that would accommodate
all three but obviously ross will be
able to say more
tomorrow um the drains are done on this
three-year cycle
but but because when we get a down
paused and the water runs down the hill
the drains don't capture all the water
they capture as much as they can but
some goes past
so that's obviously um a frequent
thing that comes up and the library as
far as i know
um rogers roger crowd who's the cabinet
member dealing with it hasn't told me
any different
the money is ring fenced um it should be
going
libraries into the arts center at some
point
with the library and learn devon sharing
the building
um originally it was going to go for
planning last february it didn't
um mps who were doing it didn't appoint
um
a project manager until later this year
so um roger always promises to keep me
updated and he's not sent me anything to
say it's all off
so hopefully that's still going ahead
because the library we've got is not fit
for purpose the building um
from a library point of view there's
only one toilet for the staff and any
and it's in the sort of room where
they'd have their snacks
it's just not very suitable um trying to
think of anything else
i think that was oh when jamie mckenzie
was
talking about the money that the um
county councillors get
i believe it wasn't referring to our
locality budget i think about our share
of the pothole action fund
depending on how many miles we've got so
barry
and andrew saywell have got bigger areas
than me and always get more money
i've got more than andrew eastman so
it's all done on miles
and then you we consult with a highway
officer what are our priorities
and now priorities are usually the
things that the parish councils have
been telling us
are their priorities anyway sorry if
that's gone on a bit john but
but that was my i forgot that it was on
mileage
because i have more than some of my
colleagues down here
um the more miles you have in your
parish
or your you're sorry on your wards the
more money you get
so although you may only have five
county cashiers in torridge
the area of road you get is apportioned
the same as the rest of the county if
it's an
exeter or anybody else you still only
get
the money in relation to the miles of
road you have in your area
right okay thank you can we move on
yeah uh phil pennington where are you
phil
oh yeah you're on phil
yeah just on muted can you hear me chair
yep
yeah okay okay thank you john for coming
thank you chair
um slightly different focus um i read on
your
devon website uh john that the the
carers have now risen by
half to 130 000 devon residents and
their carers in the county partly do
with all the covered and the pressures
on covet
and yet i understand only 20 000 are
accessing devon carers
um i you know i get a lot of stories
coming through
of pressure on the social care etc etc
i also understand that you're trying to
do a policy of uh skilling
k um the social care aspects as well
um the budget must be under tremendous
pressure
and i just wondered how we can actually
encourage new carers
to get hold of information about what
they can actually do because
carers should get a an assessment when
they get into the role of caring
but it appears sometimes talking to one
or two around the area who are new care
as one of the
probably 35 000 new carers since march
um
why they they haven't had their care
assessment done
and i just wondered if you could just
talk a little bit around the social care
aspect here please
i can't answer you again in detail on
that one yes
proud to care it's been a campaign we've
been running now for some months
we started at the beginning of the
pandemic and we certainly had quite a
number of people volunteer to come in
and work for the county council
um we have an awful lot of people being
looked after
some by the local authorities some they
pay their own
we also have 330 care homes in devon
eight and a half thousand people in them
of which two and a half thousand
are local government sponsored clients
i would guess if we have not had an
assessment
it would be a lot more to do with kelvik
19 than anything else
but i can get that looked at because i
would have thought
new carers would need the support
that should be available to them
because when they first come into the
caring profession
they need to they need support they need
confidence they need help
so i can look at that but i can't answer
the question
i do know on our website we have
protocare
we've run a couple of campaigns recently
on protocure
and we are always looking for extra
people to come and work with us
okay and also yeah i'm also john looking
at the um
personal family carers who don't realize
that they become
carers you know a lot of people are
hidden carers because they're the
husband the wife
the child of a mother um or a father who
have got health problems in various ways
and it's identifying themselves as the
carer now that's been the difficulty
because nobody's actually working with
them any longer
we have cut down an awful lot by using
zoom etc
unless people come to us we wouldn't
necessarily
know they're there okay
it's on the website where you can ask
for help
i think that's the message i've got to
give okay
thank you i'm still looking at young
people
children that are carers trying to
support them as well
right what i can do is um put a link in
john
when i um i'll send it to tom or
somebody
i'll put a link into the dev and carers
website and that is for
family carers informal carers for them
to access support so if i put that link
in
then um local counselors will be able to
share that with their
own communities thank you very much
thank you both thank you alison thank
you john all right thank you
okay move on james mills town clark
northam
where are you yeah okay
okay um yeah thank you thank you for
letting me speak i wanted to
wanted to ask what what help that the
county could possibly
offer to help alleviate the major
parking problems we've got in apple door
which were
really really severe this year
particularly with people coming down to
stay in campervans et cetera
i said i can't really answer that
question in detail
if there are areas that the county
uh the people are parking and they
shouldn't be parking
the time council the county councillors
can ask for some
awaiting restrictions are gone
if we have areas where you've got car
parks
and they're being monopolized by the
campervans and i think this may be
something i heard about
on the radio a couple of days ago
then i think if it's private land
belonging to the district council
they would need to bring in some form of
legislation
what east devon has done recently is
permitted parking up till about 10 p.m
but then they've got to go or they get
booked
so no longer is it 24 hours parking or
24 hour
free parking but
somebody's put up a note here a
consultational residence parking scheme
did you have one did it get turned down
by the residents
well have you never had it was there was
one yeah there was one
a few years ago and marginally it was
rejected by
residents but i think there is there's a
fight for it now
yeah i mean the other major problem that
we have is the parking on the slipway
which belongs to devon county council
um but just it's not enforced so
it blocks the boat park and it makes
life very difficult down there
but no we can't get any support for
um you know people being
fined or anything like that for parking
where they shouldn't be
if you're parking on the slipway
[Music]
or anything on it or not
right on the slipway all the yellow
lights
yes but that nobody enforces it
well if there are parking restrictions
i would have thought it's time somebody
did start enforcing it
if they are not marking arrangements or
restrictions
then i think it's on slipways in
particular
it would make sense for some parking
restrictions to be put there
who would put them there well as far as
i'm aware there are restrictions but
they're not being enforced
and we're finding it difficult to get
support to make them enforced
so if you can do anything to help there
we'd be very
certainly find out grateful there are
any restrictions on it i think
who will put it on the tongue cancer
requested
they write in country cancer support it
would go to the hattock
and the hatter would then decide whether
to approve it or not
i've got a funny feeling that steve erst
wants to come in here
is that right steve uh yes thanks chair
uh thanks councilman hardin thanks jane
and sorry is something that's been
reported to
our community resources committee
yesterday um because the two
ward members councillor haines and
councillor ford
uh council ford in particular brought a
notice of notice of motion to
torres full council meeting so that was
considered
particularly in respect to the the
mobile homes and campervans
at committee yesterday and an approval
made by committee to restrict
parking of campervans to a particular
area of the car park
um in addition to that sean curdy and i
met
councillor james and councillor ford at
church fields car park
some weeks ago to look at the problems
there
and we are looking at what options
around enforcement
etc can be put in place for next summer
um i think we also had a conversation
with councillor
chalmers uh recently to work
together with northern town council to
look at options
uh around parking in appledore so that's
something on the
agenda for us to do as well okay thank
you
thank you very much that's how i heard
about it i got steve
uh headlamp on uh about the campervans
on the radio
a couple of days ago
okay uh i've got one more round and
we're going to make this the last one
and it's counsellor
right okay have i missed doug smith from
somewhere then
doug where is he uh
yes i'm here again if you can hear me oh
have you only just put your hand up uh i
did a while ago and i cancelled it
because i thought it wasn't being seen
so uh my pleasure i can see they're all
in line here
excellent um two things i'd like to say
um
with reference to the places like the
targa trail and cycling
when uh the railways were originally
introduced the four foot nine and a half
gauge
was arrived at
by the width of the back side of two
chariot horses in roman days
now the target trail
should be able to cope two horses side
by side if it can't cope with a single
one
it strikes me that the encroachment of
trees and shrubbery at the side is is
getting out of hand
and we ought to really look at um look
at controlling that because obviously
it's very bad for horses for cyclists
for pedestrians etc etc
so it's um it should technically be the
width
of i'm not going to go back into it
again but the
the width of two horses um the other
point i'd like to make very briefly if i
may
uh and i'd support councillor christie
in this one um
we're talking about uh flooding and i'm
i'm a parish councillor at little
torrington as well as
i'm also a town councillor at great
torrington but we had a lot of
runoff um from fields coming down and
flooding our village a number of houses
were flooded um this last winter
um councillor say well very kindly um
was involved
um i spent time in wellington boots in
ditches trying to
clear drains and doing stuff because i
was the the person that people knew
and you're always in the firing line
aren't you um
but there was a huge amount of water
coming down to the village
some of which was drains that hadn't
been cleared from
many many years but some of some of it
was caused by
inadequate drainage and i'm sure
councillor sewell will
will be able to elucidate on that
further than i can but i would appeal
that if any um
investigation is done in either
biddeford or
um or northern because i believe there's
a problem there as well um i would
appeal for them pleased to come across
to
a great torrington and uh and speak to
me about the teleport issues it's all
pretty much
part and parcel of the same thing thank
you chair
yeah can i just say that councillor say
well has had to leave the meeting he had
another meeting that he had to go to
it's at giles in the wood um but i will
pass that message on to him
okay thank you alec right i'm gonna make
this the last question
because i think john's probably had
enough
um so thank you very much for the
explanation on the width of the trail
um very interesting very interesting
okay well uh can i thank you for
listening
i have my hand up yes i know i i was
just gonna tell you to speak
okay but make it brief phillip i will
make it brief
um actually just to enlighten the
committee even further
the width of the rail gauge on railway
trains
goes back to the width of axles
that are found back at roman um
forts including on the hadrian's wall so
it's something that even predates that
it's a standard width of
a cartwheel exactly but um
importantly i've got i better split this
into two parts
um you made comments about the financial
standing of torres district council with
chairwood and governance
um i i would wish you to expand on
actually about the financial health
as you see it of torres district council
and secondly is devon county council
likely or is definitely likely to become
a unitary
are there discussions about it what are
the um
how do you foresee the future as you see
that at the moment
last question and that is the last
question
thank you chair and thank you very much
john for everything
tonight it's much appreciated right
first question is financial standing
torres is one of the highest affected on
the hospitality trade
and that came very clear when we were
looking at the first
lockdown on the pandemic um but it was
actually highlighted a short while ago
on the second lockdown as one of the top
10 in the country
for a week economy whereas exeter was
highlighted
as one of the top 10 for a weak economy
because of what it borrowed now
because you are very centered
on the hospitality trade
you have been very badly affected we had
a session today with members of
parliament
and steve hurst was there and they plea
was put up in no uncertain terms
that at the present moment if we have a
lockdown stay in tier 2 until feb march
up to 70 percent of the hospitality
trades
will have gone because they cannot
afford to continue
they have no income and they said even
amazon would struggle if it had no
income for two months
let alone six to eight months
now that message went clearly back to
the members of parliament
what also impact was the fact
that we are now having unfortunately
a few suicides because of the pressure
some of these small businesses are on
so that is a worry it is why we've
actually issued another press statement
today
calling upon the government to
give more support to the hospitality
industry
because if you can't open you can't open
if you can open but you can only take a
quarter of the people
your cards open because you may be
having money
but you're running at a loss exactly the
same
there's a football clubs and the rugby
clubs
the issue of unitary council is a lot
simpler
there was move last year beginning of
this year
for some local authorities to lead the
charge
unitary councils three have gone through
um literally relatively short time ago
somerset cambria and
i can't remember the third one what we
have had
just before the second lockdown was the
fact that the counties were told they
could go
when the lockdown came it slowed
everything up
and we were all told to get to put our
arms around our districts
because we need to work as a team
for the benefit of the community in all
local councils
some local councils were looking to go
and they were not given the right to go
they have had serious arguments between
county and district
even those that have gone have got
arguments between county and districts
you've got a choice in somerset one
county
two small county or two small units one
unitary
two small unitaries the possibility
of linking some to north somerset
north somerset is now fallen out with
bristol
because he's not allowed to join the
west of england
local enterprise partnership so there's
all sorts of problems
i said at the beginning knowing what i
knew
i would not face gopher a unitary
council
for them and it was twofold
one is the optimum size is five to six
hundred thousand people
if we were to start with devil we're too
big
if we were and what they said if you go
for unity
you have to take into consideration the
existing
unitary councils so if devon had
torbay added to it it's 950
000. if plymouth is from him it's 1.2
million
you then divide devil into two
equal parts it has to go
on district council areas
whatever you divided you finish up
with a rich report at canti or richie
editor
and a poorer unitary i've said all along
i would be opposed to making any part of
devon county
poorer i also said that a county
the size of devil with 800 000 electors
has a capacity that most of our other
neighbors don't have
dorset was divided in half linked with
paul and bournemouth
the first thing that happened with the
first lockdown was that dorsey said we
could go broke
devin will not go broke devon will offer
a service
as long as i'm here and the government
asks
i won't go for this unitary scenario
theoretically on a unitary devin i might
now use what might save some money
the fight between county and district
will be such
that it is not worth the benefits if
there are any benefits
coming out of it if we were to go
and divide devon in two pieces we would
lose our capacity
lose our benefits and the people would
be losers
so you got my you've had my comment
before casper hackett
i've given it to you again thank you
thank you very much indeed thank you
very much indeed john i really do
appreciate that and putting it on the
record
um and the greater depth that you've
given this time
thank you okay thank you all
very much for listening to me
i've got a full cabinet meeting tomorrow
you better get off then
so i'm gonna have to go get some more
lozenges i've run out of lozenges
tonight
but tomorrow night we finish early but
thank you all for coming
thank you for so many of you coming this
time yep
and we have got a lot of questions we
will get you back
a lot of answers if you do come back
with the answers john
yep okay thank you very much nice to see
you
okay good night good night good night
john thank you
john chair i'm just checking if this
meeting is carrying on i probably better
go and start
dealing with the lists okay okay
that's fine all right thanks very much
and i'll see you all when i see you
yeah bye bye
okay okay well
i just hope this next one's not gonna go
on long
oh it might do then because steve's
there
okay steve it's your turn now mate okay
just do an update from you yeah sure if
you like i'll just keep it briefly then
if
you like um we're not going to cover
anything um
similar to what counselor hardcover but
just
put in a little bit of context uh
locally
um obviously as a district council we're
having
the same kinds of issues in terms of
managing budgets because of lack of
information and late information from
coming from from government in terms of
uh grand settlements and the like um so
i guess contextual contextually it's
still the same issues but obviously the
the numbers
are far smaller but that doesn't mean
uh the decisions that our councillors
have to make any less
difficult it's just in a smaller area
um so what uh the other things council
heart mentioned around
council tax um and as he said storage is
the billing authority so we
have to give uh the council tax we
collect to devon county
and as he mentioned regardless of our
collection rate for this year we still
have to pay
the same amounts uh to the county
council to the police to the fire party
and to parish councils so
um in cash terms all of those uh
individual organizations would receive
the same amount as they would done if we
collected
100 percent this year what does happen
is when we come into 2021
22. now obviously the
impact of covid on council tax and
council tax collection uh will push that
down um so what that means
is when uh torridge sets his
council tax base which we'll be doing at
our full council
full council meeting next monday um
the council tax base will be lower so
there's
in effect less properties paying
abandoned
council tax so that means for the likes
of parish and town councils
is they have to increase council tax
the council tax preset just to retain
the status quo
if that makes sense i'm happy to ask any
questions you
if you want growth in your base you'll
have to in effect increase it twice
once to make up the the shortfall in
uh normal collection and a further time
to
increase any growth also you're not
partisan town councils are not affected
by lack of collection
whatever you said and whatever your
precept on porridge district
that's what's paid so we'll be setting
our council tax base next week
and david hayes and peter hudson will be
circulating
uh the council tax bases for parish and
town councils
um in the next couple of days so you'll
have that information to set your parish
and town council precepts
um on kovid related matters i see
council hart mentioned
uh devon uh tier two
and his thoughts of where where we will
be next week when the the next hearing
is um issued obviously i'm sure you'll
be aware that sorry for
a long period of this year uh had the
lowest
incidence rate uh in terms of cope with
infections
that has changed in the the last couple
of weeks
um as he mentioned it had gone up
in many areas across devon and
torridge uh in fact went above a hundred
per hundred thousand at the earlier part
of this week
um that is largely in relation
to our over 80s
age group and so predominantly
areas in care homes and substantially to
do with
extra testing those
rates have started to come down in the
last day or so
i think as of today it's 89
per 100 thousand so we are seeing uh
movement
in the the dominant direction as we
would like to see
um he did obviously talk at uh in detail
about the impact on hospitality
and the fact that the meeting was held
today with the german mps which
as he said i was i was on uh so there's
a presentation
from the southwest tourism alliance
which spelled out in detail the impact
of
tier two on the the hospitality sector
and some information was
as i said surplay then presented at that
meeting which i'll
be able to share it only came through
later this afternoon so i haven't had an
opportunity to circulate that
to our counselors but i'll get that
circulated uh
tomorrow so that's all i really want to
cover
on on that um obviously we'll be looking
at our budget and david hayes our
section one type one officer
will be presenting information to our
community resources committee
in the new year highlighting the the
difficulties we will have
and our members will have in set in
torridge's budget
next year and some of the difficult
decisions that uh
they'll be posed with uh during that
process
with the the kind of final budget
meeting uh being
in the 22nd of february
um aside from that other plans
um obviously during the the course of
this year we've had quite a few
changes in terms of uh management
obviously i was appointed in july this
year and since then
um i've undertaken a restructure of our
senior management team and our
operational management team
and we've almost concluded all of the
interviews and appointments to posts and
sean kearney is our head of communities
in place and stacey
dory our head of legal and governments
is on on the meeting uh this evening
um and as soon as the the final
appointments are made
i'll circulate to all parish clerks
the the new structure with the names so
um everybody knows who to contact
um within torridge okay i think that's
all i've got to add i guess this is the
first
joint area advisory group meeting we've
had
um particularly on a zoom function
so going forward in terms of support to
your
three normal area area meetings
um i'll probably continue to do the the
holesworthy
uh advisory group meeting sean will pick
up the
northern biddeford dumbledore and rural
and
stacy will be there to support the the
torrenting meeting
so you'll have cover for all of those uh
meetings
if and when uh we resume uh
those on a area by area basis okay i'm
happy to take any questions if there are
any
but i said i would keep it briefly steve
tony inch
thank you chair well it's not a question
on this just that
i just wanted um before you know ask
members that
i do send out my updates from um them
county council
whenever i get them and i just i don't
get much feedback from anybody actually
but
i hope that you all read them and you
all enjoy
them or whatever you do with them um but
um
i will go on and send them right because
i think they are
sort of like good information for
everybody to have a look at
so i hope you you do read them and um
you know they give you some sort of
information of of them carry counsel or
what they're doing
hey fine for me tony
anybody oh oh doc
counselor i thought you'd done it very
briefly
i would just like to thank tony inch
for sending his information out because
i don't even get it from our county
councillor
and it is very very much appreciated
he's a very hard-working counsellor
and i thank him for sparing the time and
sending them out to us all
i really do it's much appreciated yeah
well done tony any more questions
for steve before i
tell him we were finished no
okay right you got a flight steve
well time is it 8
10 8 13.
meet it we'll close the meeting now okay
tom